go go hi brother hey guys Aron Kader
bringing a quick overview of the 2.1
patch for diablo 3 reaper of souls which
has come out on the public test realm
firstly seasons will act similarly two
ladders in diablo 2 it now allows
players to start fresh in a new season
to witness who will be the first to
level the seventy amongst other notable
achievements the next big feature and
new endgame content are greater rifts in
order to open a greater rift you will
have to do normal riffs in which case
the rift Guardians have a chance to drop
your greater rift keystone greater rifts
allow players to traverse through a time
drift and they become more and more
difficult as you finish them greater
rifts range from level 1 to level 100
with a 15 minute timer for each rib as
you beat each greater rift you will
continue to a higher level which will
increase the monster health and damage
level 1 is quite easy but by the time
you get into the level 20 greater rifts
the difficulty jumps immensely
leaderboards our new feature that are
also coming with 2.1 the leaderboards
will track both hardcore and normal mode
your furthest greater rift level and the
time you spent evita will be put on the
leaderboard as well which will then
allow you to compare yourself to the
rest of the world in regards to either
your specific class or your party
success also another part of the leader
board consists of conquests which are
specific achievements you would try to
finish
the sewer level cesspools from AG five
that was not included in Reaper of souls
has now been added to riffs and greater
rifts another knee area to discover in
this patch is a treasure realm to get to
the charger realm you'll have to kill
treasure goblins and hope they open the
portal for you here you'll find all the
riches from the goblins you let survive
in previous playthroughs you'll even get
to fight greed herself in the vault of
the treasure realm you seasonal
legendaries will also be added as well
as a revamping of previous legendaries
and set items many class changes and
balances have been made as well these
will change that the PTR goes through
its iterations but new passes buffs and
nerfs have been handed out to each class
for more in-depth look at class balance
and skill changes check out the hablo
3.com these are some of the big features
coming with the 2.1 patch you can test
them now by joining the PTR remember PTR
will be wiped so everything you find
will not last nor will your leaderboard
standings stay tuned to gamespot com for
more diablo 3 reaper of souls content
you